- I can skate and you
can film, or something.
- I'll catch it all.
- Let's do it.
One of the first times I came
to California
for a competition,
I was 14 and saw all the
girls that I had looked up to.
And I guess that's the
first time that I realized
this is way cooler
than I even thought.
- So you're preparing
for the Olympics.
You were born in Texas,
grew up in Hawaii,
currently live in San Diego.
Now you're going to
be going to Tokyo.
Did you ever think
that skateboarding
would take you that far?
- Definitely not.
It was never a thought really
to make a career out of it when
I first started skateboarding.
So for now, to be the
first year in the Olympics,
it's pretty crazy
how far it's come.
This is the biggest
competition in the world,
so I want to be as
ready as possible.
I'm very excited
just to go to Japan
and meet all the other athletes
from so many different sports
and watch them compete
and learn from them
and have the whole
Olympic experience.
OK, so I'm thinking for a
little follow film line—
- As an NBA player,
I go through tons
of emotions, tons of
different types of training
from, obviously, regular
season to the postseason.
For you, going
from skating around
with your friends,
obviously you medal at 17,
you're an Olympian at 22.
How does your focus,
training, mindset
shift as you prepare
for Tokyo once you
get into the actual
skating competition?
- I try to definitely
keep my mindset similar.
You know, keep it the same, keep
skating, keep doing it
because I love it.
That should never
change in my opinion.
- It's a very lonely road
because of the sacrifices
you have to make to get
there, but once you do, it's
definitely worth it.
- Go that way a tiny bit.
Now you're good.
- All right, not moving.
I'm here.
- Skateboarding has
changed my life.
You go to the skate park and you
don't just learn skateboarding.
You learn a million
life lessons.
You learn to keep getting
up after you fall, accept
everyone.
It doesn't matter
if you're good,
you're bad, what race you
are, what gender you are.
We're all just
here skateboarding,
and we're all having fun, and
everyone encourages everyone.
It's not like any other sport.
- Bravo, bravo, bravo.